Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Avez-vous déjà eu la chance
d'observer une aurore boréale ?
Bon, en plein jour, c’est impossible.
Et en région parisienne,
c'est extrêmement rare.
Mais plus au nord, en Norvège par exemple,
le phénomène est beaucoup plus fréquent.
Alors, comment le ciel peut-il s’illuminer ainsi ?
Et comment mettre toutes les chances
de son côté pour observer une ?
Suivez-moi, je vais vous éclairer.
C'est beau, hein ?
Faute d'aurore boréale dans le ciel parisien,
j'ai mis la main sur un appareil
qui reproduit le phénomène.
Mouais.
Bah, on fait ce qu'on peut, hein ?
Bon, je reprends.
Et d'abord une petite précision.
Je parle d'aurores boréales,
mais on devrait dire aurores polaires,
car le phénomène se produit au niveau
des deux pôles :
nord et sud.
Et si dans l'hémisphère nord
on parle d'aurores boréales,
du latin boreas,
qui signifie “vent du Nord”
dans l'hémisphère sud,
on parle d'aurores australes.
C'est ici, au-dessus
du cercle polaire, qu'on a le plus
de chances d'assister à ce spectacle.
Précisément,
dans une zone appelée Ovale Auroral.
Il s'agit d'une bande d'une
centaine de kilomètres qui s'étend
entre 65 et 75 degrés de lattitude nord.
Pour voir une aurore boréale,
enfin, avoir une chance d'en observer une,
il faut donc se rendre
dans le nord de la Scandinavie,
le nord de la Russie,
en Islande, au Groenland,
dans le Grand Nord canadien ou en Alaska.
Comme je l'ai dit plus tôt,
le phénomène se déroule aussi au pôle Sud,
mais dans une zone
beaucoup plus difficile d'accès.
Si les aurores polaires n'ont jamais cessé
d'alimenter l'imagination des Hommes,
c'est parce qu'elles prennent
parfois des formes étranges.
Comme ce visage d'extraterrestre
sur un cliché du photographe
Lurie Belegurschi.
Ces jeux de lumières multicolores
sont en réalité
liés à l'activité du Soleil.
Vous le savez,
notre étoile produit
de la lumière, mais pas que.
Elle émet aussi un flot ininterrompu
de particules chargées électriquement,
principalement
des protons et des électrons.
Sous l'effet des réactions
qui se déroulent dans le Soleil,
ces particules sont éjectées,
propulsées dans l'espace à une vitesse
d'environ
1 300 000 kilomètres par heure.
Elles forment ce que l'on appelle le “vent
solaire”.
S'il pénétrait dans l'atmosphère,
ce vent solaire
empêcherait toute vie ou presque,
car les particules sont radioactives.
Mais si c'est radioactif,
c'est dangereux, alors ?
Non, parce qu'à l'approche
de la Terre, le vent solaire se heurte
au champ magnétique terrestre.
Il agit comme un bouclier
qui empêche ces particules
d'atteindre le plancher des vaches.
Il dévie environ 98%
des particules qui continuent leur voyage
dans l'espace.
Toutefois, un petit pourcentage
arrive à forcer le passage
et à pénétrer le champ magnétique.
Ces particules se heurtent
alors aux lignes de champ qui forment
de grands arcs entre les pôles.
Elles suivent ces lignes
et pénètrent dans l'atmosphère.
À ce niveau, comme dans un entonnoir,
et là, c'est le feu d'artifice.
Les protons et les électrons bourrés
d'énergie entrent en
collision avec les atomes
qui composent la haute atmosphère
d'autres grains de matière.
Ceux-ci s'excitent à leur tour
et libèrent l'énergie qu'ils ont accumulé.
Ils la libèrent sous forme de lumière.
Ce sont les fameuses aurores boréales.
Et tu es vraiment sûr qu'on craint rien ?
Mais non, je te rassure,
les aurores boréales
ne présentent aucun danger pour la santé.
Elles se produisent
si haut dans l'atmosphère
qu'elles sont parfaitement inoffensives
pour ceux qui les observent depuis le sol.
Elles forment de grands drapés
de lumière qui ondulent dans le ciel
entre 80 et 300 kilomètres
au dessus de nos têtes.
Elles vont et viennent
en fonction
de la puissance du vent solaire
qui souffle par rafale.
C'est beau, hein ?
Si les aurores boréales
nous fascinent autant,
c’est qu'elles peuvent prendre des couleurs
très différentes.
Vert, rouge, bleu, mauve.
Il y en a pour tous les goûts.
Ces couleurs varient en fonction
de la nature des atomes qui sont excités.
On dit aussi
qu'ils sont ionisés
par les particules solaires,
mais également en fonction
de leur altitude dans l'atmosphère.
Lorsque les particules solaires ionisent
des atomes d'oxygène situés
à basse altitude,
un rayonnement de couleur verte est émis.
Comme ce rayonnement est proche de nous
et que le vert est une couleur
que notre oeil perçoit facilement,
les aurores vertes
sont les plus fréquentes.
Mais lorsque les atomes d'oxygène ionisés
sont situés
à plus de 200 kilomètres
au dessus de nos têtes,
ils émettent dans le rouge
un rouge très profond,
difficilement perceptible à l'œil nu.
Parfois, l'horizon se remplit
d'un camaïeu mauve, bleu, rose ou blanc.
Ces couleurs sont émises
par des atomes
d'azote situés proches de nous.
Alors, pour assister à ce show,
il faut attendre la nuit,
car il est impossible de percevoir
les aurores boréales en pleine journée.
La lumière émise par
les atomes de l'atmosphère
n'est pas suffisamment puissante.
Enfin, vous le savez, au niveau des pôles,
la nuit ne dure qu'une partie de l'année.
Il faut donc choisir la
bonne saison pour s'y rendre.
Dans l'hémisphère nord,
la bonne période se situe entre novembre
et mars.
Les nuits sont très sombres
et très longues.
Elles durent 20 h,
à la fin du mois de décembre,
c'est-ce qu'on
appelle “la nuit polaire”.
Mais les chasseurs d'aurores boréales
préfèrent les mois de janvier et de février.
À cette époque de l'année,
il ne neige quasiment pas.
Le ciel est donc bien dégagé.
Il est aussi préférable de choisir
les périodes
dites de nouvelle lune ou de lune noire.
Ces jours-là, la lune est cachée.
L'obscurité est alors maximale
et les aurores sont plus visibles.
Le clou du spectacle se situe
généralement
entre 8 h du soir et 1 h du matin.
Mais attention,
les aurores boréales ne sont visibles
que quelques instants.
Heureusement,
elles peuvent revenir très vite.
Avec un peu de chance,
le spectacle peut se prolonger
durant plusieurs heures.
Le lieu idéal se situerait au nord
de la Norvège, sur l'archipel du Svalbard.
Si vous souhaitez vous y rendre,
prévoyez des moufles et une polaire.
Les températures peuvent
descendre jusqu'à -30 degrés.
Un Français que tout le monde connaît
a déniché un lieu beaucoup plus incongru
pour photographier les aurores boréales.
Thomas Pesquet. Regardez ces images.
Le spationaute les a immortalisé
depuis la Station spatiale internationale.
On peut voir très nettement
les arcs auroraux vert
onduler au dessus de la Terre.
En Norvège, il fait trop froid...
Dans l'espace, j'irai jamais...
Je n'ai aucune chance
de voir une aurore boréale, moi.
C'est vrai, c'est très rare,
mais ça peut arriver.
Dans la nuit du 25 janvier 1938,
une aurore boréale
a embrasé le ciel parisien.
Alors, comment est-ce possible ?
Eh bien, il arrive parfois
que les flux de particules
émis par le Soleil
soient si violents que le vent solaire vire à la tempête.
A l'approche
de la Terre,
cette tempête déforme
les lignes du champ magnétique.
La zone dans laquelle
les particules solaires
entrent en contact avec l'atmosphère
s'agrandit,
permettant aux particules de pénétrer
jusqu'aux tropiques.
Ces tempêtes solaires peuvent également
créer des orages magnétiques capables
de perturber
les réseaux électriques et Internet
sur une bonne partie du globe.
On parle alors de black out,
mais rien à voir
avec celui qu'on redoute en ce moment,
qui lui est lié à un manque d'électricité.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus
sur ce phénomène de black out lié
aux tempêtes solaires,
j'ai fait une vidéo sur le sujet.
Vous pouvez la consulter en cliquant ici.
J'y explique que le Soleil
entre dans une phase
d'activité maximale
tous les onze ans en moyenne.
Les tempêtes solaires sont
alors plus fréquentes
et les aurores boréales plus intenses.
Le prochain pic d'activité
est prévu pour 2025 et à mon avis,
comme d'habitude, de nombreux Japonais
feront le voyage jusqu'au Grand Nord.
Selon une légende tenace,
au pays du Soleil levant,
faire l'amour
après avoir observé une aurore boréale
augmenterait les chances
d'avoir un enfant.
Allez, on en profite une dernière fois.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout.
J'espère
qu'elle vous a donné envie d'enfiler
vos moufles et vos doudounes
et de vous rendre
dans le cercle polaire pour admirer
une vraie aurore boréale.
Allez, à très bientôt,
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.